call her name three times in front of a
mirror and her ghost will appear the
story of Bloody Mary is one that many of
us are familiar with today we examine
the origins of one of the individuals
believed to have been Bloody Mary
Elizabeth báthory was one of the most
notorious female serial killers of all
time and was later given the nickname
countess Dracula she was born in
Transylvania in 1560 to a distinguished
royal family she had a great education
and was blessed with good looks and
enormous wealth Elizabeth's family were
made up of kings Cardinals and Knights
despite this her family tree still
possessed a dark side she was taught
sadomasochism from her aunt and her
uncle was rumored to be a Satanist Beth
remarried at the age of 15 and in order
to please her her husband built her her
very own torture chamber with her
husband constantly off to war and having
given birth to four children she had
developed a reputation as a cruel
mistress routinely beaten her servants
to ease her boredom she was particularly
known to enjoy torturing her female
servants with the death of her husband
Elizabeth was finally free to do as she
pleased and her behavior became worse
she continued to torture her servants
and her list of techniques were
ever-growing jamming pins and needles
under fingernails and smothering victims
in honey and leaving them to be attacked
by bees and ants or monks her favorite
torture methods now in her early 40s
Elizabeth was desperate to find a way to
stay young she turned to dark magic but
none of the ritual she had tried
appeared to be working one morning
Elizabeth's maid had angered her somehow
and in a fit of rage the counter struck
her across her face blood poured from
the maids nose and spattered Elizabeth's
hand after wiping the blood away she had
noticed her skin looked much smoother
upon seeing this she ordered the maid to
be killed and her blood to be drained
into a tub so she could bathe in it
Elizabeth believed that she had
discovered the secret to ever lost in
youth she continued to use the blood of
virgins as part of her beauty regime
even going as far as to drink it as her
thirst for blood grew Elizabeth began
abducting unmarried peasant girls from
nearby villages to continue the
addiction of maintain in her youth
the girls were reported missing and the
locals claimed that they had been taken
by Elizabeth however the local
government was indeed run by Elizabeth's
family and her crimes were ignored the
supply of virgin peasant girls began to
run dry and it wasn't until Elizabeth
began abducting the daughters of local
lords and nobles that King Matthias had
to intervene in January of 1611 Bathory
was put on trial for over 80 counts of
murder anyone who had ever helped her
had been convicted but she managed to
escape execution as it was against
Hungarian law to convict a noble person
instead she was confined to a sealed
room in the castle with tiny slits which
were used to pass food through
she survived there for three years
before eventually being found dead in
August of 1614 Elizabeth never once
showed any remorse for her actions in
her three years of confinement it is
believed that Elizabeth báthory was
responsible for the death of over 600
people do you believe the countess was
the woman behind the tales of Bloody
Mary what does our search continue if
you've enjoyed this video then please go
ahead and leave it a like consider
subscribing if folklore mythology is
something that interests you if you have
anything you'd like to discuss or have
any ideas for future videos then please
go ahead and let me know in the comments
below as always I've been your host
mythology and folklore explained